un mur comme un écrin un mur de 32 km
qui ceint le projet d'un homme d'un roi
surnommé aussi le prince architecte
françois 1er son projet créer une
merveille du monde destinés à
immortaliser son bâtisseur septembre
1519 le roi ordonne la construction de
chambord chambord qui doit servir aussi
de résidence de chasse et nécessite la
création d'un parc où le gibier soit
abondant virginie doctorante en histoire
chargée de recherche à chambord est
notre guide
elle nous donne rendez vous dans un
paysage bien différent du cadre boisé
associé à l'image de chambord en fait à
l'époque de françois 1er au 16e siècle
nous sommes sur un territoire -
forestier il ya encore de grandes
plaines des prêts des terres agricoles
il ya aussi quelques paysages de landes
et fut des marais aux abords du château
et françois 1er choisi ce terrain parce
qu'il a une réputation très joyeux et
d'ailleurs les comptes de blois avait
fait construire ici à l'emplacement du
château actuel
une première résidence dans laquelle il
venait lorsqu'il voulait chasser sur les
terres giboyeuse de chambord et de
boulogne
chambord est à deux heures de cheval du
château royal de blois
c'est un lieu idéal leroy et chassera
avec sa petite bande iii semble aussi
plus proches sujet mais le jeune roi
auréolée de ses victoires porte avant
tout le projet d'un chambord symbole de
modernité et de grandeur son projet
c'est de construire une résidence de
plaisance et en même temps le château de
chambord c'est aussi pour lui
l'envy de créer un bâtiment de génie
architectural
qui va éblouir et d'ailleurs il fait
visiter les châteaux pendant son règne
c'est lors des guerres avec les riches
provinces italiennes que françois 1er
découvre la renaissance période où le
domaine des arts et des sciences innove
et bouscule les codes influencé il
invite à sa cour les meilleurs artistes
italiens dont léonard de vinci
nommé premier peintre architecte et
mécaniciens du roi il est sans doute
l'un des architectes de chambre
l'influencent italienne est évidente sur
le donjon bâtiment central voulu par
françois nous ne sommes pas dans un
grand jour médiéval sans ouverture bien
au contraire qui sert pour la défense
ici on cherche à rendre le bâtiment
élégant plus agréable à vivre
donc on perd de nombreuses ouvertures le
terme de décorent les façades sont
découpées par des moulures horizontale
par des pilastres verticaux on a aussi
des loggias on a un vrai mélange
d'architecturé françaises
traditionnelles et des apports italien
de la renaissance
ce qui nous amène à un nouveau style la
première renaissance française
le donjon commencé en 1519 sera achevée
vingt ans plus tard au total 1800
ouvriers ont travaillé sur ce projet
pharaonique un projet difficile au
milieu des marécages où le paludisme est
présent voilà le paysage reconstitué de
ce qu'on pouvait voir depuis les
fenêtres de chambre il vivre était tout
autant difficile
c'est un sauteur français premier n'a
pas habiter et très souvent et qui en
plus évident en dehors des séjours du
roi il n'y a pas de mobilier permanent
qui les meublés à l'occasion des séjours
de chasse du roi ou lorsqu'il vient
surveiller l'avancée des travaux et
c'est un château qui est effectivement
un peu inhabitables dans le sens où à
vouloir apporter ici les éléments les
plus modernes de l' architecture comme
un escalier à double révolution
on a créé des hauteurs de pièces qui
rendent les chambres de pardon 120
mètres carrés dans les plus grands
appartements impossible à chauffer
commencé en 1519 chambord sera
totalement achevée cent soixante ans
plus tard par louis xiv qui comprend le
symbole politique de jambon
chambord c'est un objet politique que
françois 1er m montrer à des
ambassadeurs à des souverains comme
charles quint qui est impressionné en
venant ici et on lui prête des mots on
dit qu'en voyant chambord il leur ai dit
j'ai vu ici l'abrégé de ce que pouvaient
l'industrie humaines françois 1er meurt
en 1549
il aura passé 70 jours au total à
chambre dernier roi chevalier les très
passionné d'art innovation il inscrit
chambord dans le paysage politique
culturelle de son temps un temps où la
renaissance marque l'avènement d'une
europe moderne